hey family it sounded like stallone not
not vin diesel but before we get started
i do want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
nordvpn nordvpn is a vpn service that
protects you your accounts and your
devices from the ever prying eyes and
the spies of the internet because we are
in the information age
data and information that's the currency
and you want to protect yours there's a
nordvpn app for windows mac os
ios android linux and even android tv
and if you're here i assume we're all
movie and tv show people so you can
still view your favorite content even if
you're abroad because you can choose
between over 5 300 servers and 59
regions so click the link below to go to
nordvpn.com
john's or enter promo code john's get
yourself a two-year plan and a bonus
gift
at a huge discount and most importantly
protect your information and thank you
once again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it right now
this is it's just
so fast nine is the ninth movie in the
fast and furious franchise funny story i
saw neil degrasse tyson
in seattle i actually his whole thing
was him talking about physics and movies
i didn't know that when i went to see
him i just wanted to see him
talk about physics i wanted a lecture
but it was like oh movies
had no idea but all right now now
there's that connection with
what i do and he made the statement
which is probably very true
i feel like it was more true before this
movie but he said
the movie armageddon breaks more laws of
physics every 15 seconds
than any movie in cinematic history it
is probably still true but after fast
nine
only just ridiculous doesn't cover this
movie and the fast and the furious
movies were movies that
i've always enjoyed well i mean since
fast five i heard they got good before
fast five but i saw the first two and i
was like okay i never saw tokyo drift
because like all right not my thing
never saw the fourth one
and then i worked at the movie theater
and had a youtube channel so i saw fast
five and i was like oh wow this
is actually pretty [ __ ] awesome the
movies since haven't been as good as
fast five but i've always been on board
you know i feel like the fast family
versus submarines is about
is apparently as much as i can take
because this movie it's like
every movie is like we have to out do
the last one problem is you get to the
point with
you're just numb i have never seen so
much [ __ ] thrown at the screen and so
much [ __ ]
thrown at the protagonists and me going
yeah i guess it's happening
that's fair things are happening a lot
of things the weird state of
indifference
i was in and i don't know how someone
could be so catatonically bored
when so many things are happening so
much [ __ ] is being thrown on screen but
there i was
actually i do know because there's no
tension you know that it's not like
dom's gonna get
cut in half by one of the 47 cars
being thrown on screen because of really
huge magnets
as they're going a hundred miles an hour
down the road he's not gonna go down
like that you know the crew's not gonna
go down like that because we've been
with them for too long this isn't game
of thrones or anything right so you know
how it's going to play out
and that's what you're doing you're just
watching it play out because you don't
need
speed for tension you don't need a lot
of action for tension the more [ __ ] you
throw on screen
actually it takes away from tension i
mean it doesn't have to you can have a
lot happen
if you establish hey this is a very
dangerous scenario but
you it never feels dangerous because
it's not dangerous it would be dangerous
if this was a movie where this didn't
happen but this is the movie so it's not
dangerous well you take that scene from
indiana jones in the last crusade
the speed at which these tanks are
driving
is 1 20th the speed of any of the cars
in this movie
the scene where indiana jones is satchel
it's caught on one of the guns
and he's about to smash into the cliff
that's pretty intense no
tension in this movie things just happen
and if you're going to go that route
i would hope the family element because
you know that's what dom toretto is all
about right like dom's all about family
until this might be spoilerish
i'm gonna all right spoilerish just so
you know i'm gonna keep this up for as
long as i talk about this and then it'll
go away right so when they were kids
something happened their dad died then
dom was like
there was a problem with dad's engine my
brother was the last one to look at the
engine
obviously he murdered our dad that was
where he went
mr family was like i'm not going to talk
to my brother i'm not going to be like
hey
did you notice a thing in dad's car no
he was like obviously
you murdered him leaps this is another
thing this movie does a lot of leaps
everyone goes
there's so many leaps people go from a
to z
and they just make these connections
that might be an exaggeration
definitely aided are pointless there's a
scene in here where tyrese gibson
and ludacris are like hey did you see
that guy's ears he has cauliflower ears
he fights for a living
obviously he's one of the bad guys but
the guy's just he's working his job and
but they turn out to be right that's a
lucky pull but
there's so many lucky pulls and if
there's no tension in the action scenes
at least there's no tension when people
are trying to figure out what's going on
because they don't actually have to try
to figure out what's going on they just
kind of
get there and even then i don't know why
dom's brother's doing what he's doing i
don't know why he's the antagonist
what's his thing he went from got
brother issues to yeah we're gonna
go ahead and enact goldeneye times a
million
because guess the money's good sure why
not as good a reason as any
that's what i have to go on it's just
the logical leap that's the leap i have
to make and i might be wrong because
this is reality
i actually love tyrus gibson and
ludacris in this movie i thought they
had great chemistry together
they're funny they have good banter it
was smart pairing them up
and keeping them paired up in this
franchise in terms of what's enjoyable
in this movie they're
out of this world zing armageddon
just it's just barely guys in the end i
feel like fast and furious has run its
course i imagine
there should be another movie because 10
is just this nice
number to end on why go to 10 when we
can stop it at nine that's just numeric
blue balls if jason
x happen there has to be a fast x right
where the fast family goes to
alpha centauri what else can they do but
it's run its course because it ceased to
be interesting you know we're not even
dealing with reality at this point it's
a movie that goes at 500 miles an hour
but has all the thrills of
standing still this might be the worst
of them because i'm not gonna remember
this movie in t minus one day
yup already forgot anyhow so fast nine
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more
click right here to see more
[Music]
you